Uno de los aspectos más extraordinarios
del cerebro humano
es su habilidad de reconocer
patrones y describirlos.
Entre los patrones más complicados
que hemos intentado comprender
está el concepto de flujo turbulento
en la dinámica de fluidos.
El físico alemán Werner Heisenberg dijo:
"Cuando me encuentre a Dios,
le haré dos preguntas:
¿Por qué la relatividad?
y ¿por qué la turbulencia?
De veras creo que tendrá respuesta
para la primera".
Tan difícil como es de entender
la turbulencia matemáticamente,
podemos usar el arte
para representar su aspecto.
En junio de 1889, Vincent van Gogh
pintó las vistas justo antes del amanecer
desde la ventana de su habitación
en el psiquiátrico Saint Paul-de-Mausole
en Saint-Rémy-de-Provence,
donde se había internado
tras mutilarse su propia oreja
en un episodio psicótico.
En "La noche estrellada",
sus pinceladas circulares
crean un cielo nocturno lleno de nubes
revueltas y remolinos de estrellas.
Van Gogh y otros expresionistas
representaron la luz
de una forma diferente
a la de sus predecesores,
pareciendo capturar su movimiento,
por ejemplo, a través
de aguas moteadas por el sol,
o aquí, en la luz de las estrellas
que parpadea y se derrite
a través de ondas blanquecinas
del cielo azul nocturno.
El efecto es causado por la luminosidad,
la intensidad de la luz
en los colores del lienzo.
La parte más primitiva
de la corteza visual,
que ve el contraste y el movimiento
de la luz, pero no el color,
mezcla dos áreas de diferente color
si tienen la misma luminosidad.
Pero la subdivisión primitiva
de nuestro cerebro
verá los contrastes de color
sin mezclarse.
Con estas dos interpretaciones
ocurriendo a la vez,
la luz en muchas obras impresionistas
pareciera vibrar, parpadear
e irradiar extrañamente.
Así es como esta
y otras obras impresionistas
usan pinceladas prominentes
ejecutadas rápidamente
para capturar algo impresionantemente real
como la forma en que se mueve la luz.
Sesenta años más tarde,
el matemático ruso Andrey Kolmogorov
impulsó nuestra comprensión
matemática de la turbulencia
cuando propuso que la energía
en un flujo turbulento a longitud R
varía en proporción 5/3 la potencia de R.
Mediciones experimentales
demuestran que Kolmogorov
estaba notablemente cerca de la forma
en que funciona el flujo turbulento,
aunque una descripción completa
de la turbulencia
aún es uno de los problemas
sin resolver de la física.
Un flujo turbulento es autosimilar
si hay una cascada de energía.
en otras palabras, los remolinos grandes
transfieren energía a los pequeños,
los cuales hacen lo mismo a otra escala.
Ejemplos de esto incluyen
la gran mancha roja de Júpiter,
formaciones de nubes
y partículas de polvo interestelar.
En 2004, usando
el telescopio espacial Hubble,
científicos vieron los remolinos
de nube de polvo y gas lejana
alrededor de una estrella,
y les recordó a la "Noche estrellada"
de Van Gogh.
Esto motivó a científicos
de México, España e Inglaterra
a estudiar la luminosidad
en las pinturas de Van Gogh con detalle.
Descubrieron que hay un patrón distinto
de estructuras de fluidos turbulentos
cercana a la ecuación de Kolmogorov
escondido en muchas pinturas de Van Gogh.
Los investigadores digitalizaron
las pinturas,
y midieron cómo el brillo varía
entre dos píxels cualquiera.
Por las curvas medidas
de las de las separaciones de píxels,
concluyeron que las pinturas del período
de agitación psicótica de Van Gogh
se comportaban de manera muy similar
a las del fluido turbulento.
Su autorretrato con una pipa,
de un periodo más calmado de Van Gogh,
no mostró signos de esta correspondencia.
ni tampoco las obras de otros artistas
que parecían igualmente turbulentos
a primera vista,
como "El grito" de Munch.
A pesar de que es muy fácil decir
que Van Gogh era un genio turbulento
capaz de representar la turbulencia,
también es muy difícil
expresar con exactitud
la belleza emocionante del hecho,
de que en un período
de sufrimiento intenso,
Van Gogh fue de alguna manera
capaz de percibir y representar
uno de los conceptos más difíciles
que la naturaleza ha puesto
ante la humanidad,
y unirse con su singular ojo mental
al misterio más profundo
del movimiento, el fluido y la luz.